-Please welcome Pete Davidson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Pete Davidson ♪
♪ Ain't no mystery ♪
♪ Pete Davidson ♪
♪ Simply can't compare ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-They love you.
-Very cool.
-That's some love.
That's some love for
Pete Davidson right there.
-It's a full crowd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right.
-Oh, wow.
-Thank you for being here.
I appreciate you coming back.
-Thanks for having me.
-"SNL" had a great season
last year.
You had had
a great season, as well,
so congrats again on that.
I wanted to ask you a question,
though, because there was
an episode where I know --
I knew you were
friends with him.
But it was
Machine Gun Kelly and you
are at the end of the show,
at goodnights,
and you're kind of
hugging and celebrating.
And then
you fall off the stage.
-Yeah.
-What was going --
What's the real story?
What happened?
-So, Colson -- or as you may
know him as Machine Gun Kelly --
he bruised his coccyx that week.
If you don't know what a coccyx
is, it's the bone in your ass.
-Okay. Oh, okay. Yeah.
-Yeah, it's from --
If you've ever seen
"Napoleon Dynamite,"
Uncle Rico says,
"Grandma took
a spill at the dunes.
She broke her coccyx."
Yeah.
-That's a good reference.
-So, I thought he was joking.
He was like,
"I broke my coccyx."
-He broke his coccyx?
-Or he bruised it.
And I was like, "Oh, that's..."
He was like, "No, for real."
So he couldn't,
like, walk or sit
and he had, like,
a tushy pillow that he was --
It was just really cool
to see, like,
the most
gangster, thug dude I know
just, like, put a little tushy
pillow down and, like, sit.
-Inflatable ring.
-Yeah, it's just, like,
Megan Fox is right there,
and he's sitting on
his little tushy pillow.
So, he was like,
"For goodnights,
we should do something,
you know, silly."
And I was like, "Or, you know,
you could just
enjoy the moment and clap."
-Yeah.
-And he was like,
"No, we'll think of something.
I'm going to,
like, pick you up."
I was like, "I don't know
if you should do that.
It's a crowded stage.
You know, we should just clap."
And he's like, "Yeah, yeah,
you're right."
And he got really excited
and he went to pick me up
and he forgot that he had
a bruised coccyx.
So he, like, went to pick me up,
and then he couldn't go up,
so he just started to
slowly tilt back.
And he went --
he went, "Oh, no."
And it was such a slow fall,
we had time for him to go,
"Oh, no," and I went,
"You're a [bleep] moron."
And --
-It was that slow of a fall.
-It was that slow.
I got the full line out.
-I have a clip.
-Oh, great.
-I want to show everyone.
Here's Machine Gun Kelly
trying to pick Pete up on "SNL."
Take a look at this.
-Yep.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, I was like, "Yo!"
-Yeah.
-That was --
-And then they
cut right after that.
They went right to --
they went right to
whatever the next thing was.
So, I went to -- Nobody ever
texts me during a show.
I went back,
there was like 40 texts like,
"Yo, you alive?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-That was so funny, dude.
-Yeah.
-Last time you were on the show,
we were talking about
"Suicide Squad" and "SNL,"
and I think I remember you
telling me that you got a dog.
And I was like,
"That's awesome."
-Yeah.
-Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-Yeah. And then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's a big deal. Yeah.
-And now you came back here
and you just told me,
backstage --
You go, "Hey, dude,
everything's cool.
I just got a dog."
And I go, "Yeah,
you told me that already."
-Yeah, I got three dogs during
the pandemic, 'cause it's hard.
No, I got the first dog,
like, for me,
but I had to leave
and go do something,
so it had to stay with my mom.
And then, when I came back,
the dog was, like,
really tight with my mom.
Like, more --
Like, it wasn't as excited
to see me as it was my mom.
So I bought another one.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And then,
same situation happened,
where I had to go away
for a little bit,
but I was like, "Can't leave it
with my mom, 'cause she --"
-No. We saw what happened.
-Yeah, I saw what
happened to the first one.
So I gave it to my sister,
'cause she's less lovable
of the Davidsons.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm just kidding.
She's wonderful.
She actually just got her coat.
She got coated.
She's, like,
a registered nurse now.
-Hey! There you go.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
So, I was like, "Safe.
I'll give her the dog."
And then I came back.
Same thing happened.
The dog was really in love
with my sister and not me.
So I bought a third dog, and now
she's with me all the time.
And this one, this one I think
is gonna stay with me. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So now you got three dogs.
-Yeah.
-I want to ask you quickly.
I know you're getting ready
to work on a couple of projects,
but one project you're working
on I'm very excited about.
You're going to play
Joey Ramone?
-Yes. That is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Thank you. Yeah.
I would also be
hesitant to clap as well.
-No.
-No, it's the craziest thing.
It was like a year or two ago,
I got a call.
They were like, "Would you like
to play Joey Ramone?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
-Of course.
-But I thought
it wasn't, like, a real thing.
And then it became a real thing.
So now, yeah, hopefully
in January or February,
we'll start.
-This is amazing, buddy.
I've never heard you sing.
-I can't.
-There you go. This is perfect.
-As a joke -- This is true.
Three years ago,
I started taking
singing lessons as a joke,
because I --
No, I just thought it would be
funny if, like, one day, like,
I was just hanging out
with the boys
and, like --
and just belted out a song.
-I know what
you're talking about.
-Yeah, you know?
-That would be a good bit.
-Just kicking it
with the boys in the most
un-song-friendly environment
and then just belt out, like,
Sinatra or something.
-So you went through it?
-Yeah, so,
I've been going to this --
For like a year,
I went to this guy who --
He's a voice coach of the stars.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-And I remember
going up to his apartment,
and he was like,
"This is so great.
This is cool
we get to work together."
He's like,
"What project is this for?"
And I was like,
"This is for my pure enjoyment."
-"Nothing. I'm just here to hang
and learn something."
-I can't sing yet,
but I know what
it's supposed to sound like.
-Alright, good.
-Yeah.
-I can't wait for that.
I think it's going to be great.
-Oh, one day,
I will belt it out.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about
this Sunday.
Madison Square Garden,
"NYC Still Rising After
20 Years: A Comedy Celebration."
Listen to all these comedians
that are going to be
at the Garden this Sunday.
Amy Schumer, Bill Burr,
Colin Jost, Colin Quinn,
Dave Attell, Dave Chappelle,
John Mulaney, Jon Stewart,
Michael Che.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm going to be there.
-Jimmy's going to be there.
-I'm gonna be -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. I appreciate that.
-Very nice of you to --
You know,
I know you're a busy guy,
so thanks for doing that.
-Are you kidding me?
You sent me a text and you go,
"Well, I might put this thing on
with Jon,
and would you be interested?"
And I go, "Anything."
Obviously, for the
city and for you, I'd do it.
But, I mean,
was it hard to get all these --
This is --
-The lineup is nuts.
Yeah, it's like
the Avengers and me.
No, it was --
It was really cool.
Me and Jon
just reached out to --
Luckily,
we have really great friends,
and we reached out,
and everybody was
super-stoked to do it.
And it was just like --
You know,
it's obviously, like,
a thing that's, like,
close to me and stuff,
so I got --
A lot of people
wanted to do, like, a thing,
like some sort of, like --
you know, like,
an article or, like --
And it all
just felt really weird.
So I just called Jon
and I was like,
"We should do something fun,
like a fun little party,
and, like,
just have a good time."
So that's how it came together.
And he does a lot, you know,
for firemen and a lot for
the city, so it was just --
-Yeah, and all the proceeds are
going to go to 9/11 charities,
I should say, so --
-Yeah.
-I'm hanging out
with Pete Davidson,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-We're about to play a game we
call "Wheel of Opinions."
Here we go.
-♪ Wheel of Opinions ♪
-Okay, I will hit this button,
which activates
the Opinion Topic Generator.
It'll land on a random topic.
Whatever it is, you have to give
your opinion on it.
You ready for this?
-Okay.
-Here we go.
First topic is...
[ Beeping ]
Corn...
Okay.
Would you rather be
caught saying, "I went glamping"
or, "I'm hangry"?
-What's glamping?
[ Laughter ]
-Glamping is -- is -- is --
People say glamping.
It's like glamorous camping,
maybe?
People go like,
"I went glamping."
Yeah, people know it.
-People say that?
-Oh, for God's sakes.
Everybody knows glamping!
Everybody knows
what glamping is!
-That is Jon Stewart
right there!
-Glamping is very popular!
-I'll move over.
-That's Jon Stewart right there!
Jon!
-Hey, Jon.
-Welcome, Jon, to our --
-Hold on.
Let me put my glasses on
so I look like my opinions
are smarter.
-Jon. Thank you, Jon.
Now, you were just streaming
the show from home?
-I'm at work.
-Yes, I'm sorry.
-I'm still at work.
You know, Peter, somebody has to
make a living in this household.
[ Laughter ]
And it's me!
-Jon...
-He comes home,
he eats the peanut butter,
he drinks the milk --
he doesn't pay!
[ Laughter ]
-I know!
Jon, do you have an opinion
on glamping or hangry?
-Either one of those should --
And, again,
I'm not a man that's speaking
for vigilante justice,
but if you were to use any,
I believe it's not improper
to tie you to the back of
a vehicle, maybe a Citi Bike --
-A Citi Bike! [ Laughs ]
-...and drag you through
perhaps Sixth Avenue.
-Yeah.
-Some people call it
the Avenue of Americas.
-Of course they do.
It's very popular.
-And to have townspeople
curse your name
and spit upon you.
-Alright, that's a good opinion.
Jon, while you're here, can we
just maybe get your opinion
on a couple other topics?
Let's try one.
-Jimmy, I was hoping you'd ask.
Here's one opinion you
may not know.
I love Pete Davidson.
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love Jon.
-That's a fact.
-He is such a good guy.
-Oh, I love that.
Alright,
how about any opinion on --
Let's see if Pete Davidson
comes up
on the
Opinion Topic Generator.
What?
Swimming with dolphins.
-How nice!
-Yeah, I have an opinion
on that.
Your generator
is full of [bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
What about my generator?
-Your -- Your --
Your topic generator!
-Yeah, why?
Swimming with dolphins --
do you have an opinion on it?
Not the generator.
-Oh, I don't have an opinion
of swimming with them,
but I am pro-blow[bleep]
That's all I'll say.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ] What's wrong --
What is wrong with you, man?
[ Laughter ]
Uh, Pete, any --
-I think it's
a lovely thing to do
with your family on vacation.
-Okay, yeah. Okay.
You think it's --
That's perfect.
Also pro-blow[bleep]
-Sure.
This is coming from a guy
who's hangry.
-Yeah, okay.
Our final topic.
Here we go.
The Opinion Topic Generator,
Jon.
-Alright, what do you got?
-Oh.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
-Mets versus Yankees.
I have a feeling where
you're gonna land, Jon.
Pete, do you have an opinion,
Mets versus Yankees?
-I always root for the Mets
because their fans are sad.
[ Laughter ]
-But as a -- When you're a
New Yorker, you get the choice,
and why -- You pick the Yankees
'cause they win.
-Yeah.
-You know, first of all...
-But I always root for --
-You don't get a choice.
-I always root for the Mets.
It's like, it would be nice
for the Mets or Jets
to win something.
-Yeah.
Jon? Jonathan?
-As a Mets fan
since the 1960s...
-Wow.
-...I accept Peter's charity.
[ Laughter ]
And as fans, we win nothing,
but it is not a choice.
My father was born in Brooklyn,
and we were not allowed
to like the Yankees.
It was -- He would rather
you smoke cigarettes
in the street
while drinking whiskey naked...
-Yeah, as a child.
-...as a 7-year-old --
by the way,
not a good father --
[ Laughter ]
-He would rather that.
-...than like the Yankees.
-That's correct.
So you are
a diehard all the way.
Mets all the way, Jon Stewart.
-I believe...
[ Bell dings ]
-...the key phrase there
is "die."
We suck.
-Pete Davidson, Jon Stewart,
everybody!
-Thanks, Jon.